with the talk show you're getting to
meet like a lot of you know music idols
and things like that anyone on your hit
list that you haven't had on the show
yet that you really want to talk to
I would I'm a huge Annie Lennox fan so I
mean I'm I'm obviously going to go
musician if I was going to go actor uh
Meryl Streep I'm a huge Meryl Streep fan
I mean God I've been able to interview
so many people that I look up to that I
that I did look up to that I still look
up to you know I'm saying like and and
that's like as far you know Julie
Andrews that was incredible I've had
Bonnie Raitt on my show which is like
one of my favorite females ever to
exists on the planet like so she's
amazing yeah like that's what I didn't
see coming right because honestly did
not think the TV show is going to do
anything I I did not think anything I
literally just you know kind of made a
deal with NBC because I love doing the
voice and I literally didn't think it
was gonna be what it is so it turned
into this just
Heavenly thing of like having a nine to
five literally with my kids in school
and that's perfect and I'm not having to
travel as much and as a parent and then
musically meeting all these incredible
artists that I look up to as they were
my idol and also new artists like I just
had Lainey Wilson right before he left
too and she's a country artist and I
love her it's just been really cool it
really it is quite amazing that you did
this talk show and again like after
American Idol a lot of people were
naysayers I think a lot of people said
Kelly Clarkson me too
she's doing a talk show but now you are
a what are you three-time Daytime Emmy
winner right uh yeah we've done so well
it's so odd and when Ellen left the biz
they gave you her time slots right that
timing was pretty just epically
incredibly cool for our show yeah that
was that was insane
um
I will say too though that was a hard
thing for me too though because I I was
on her show right after Idol like her
show started right when I won Idol like
around the same time so she had me on
like so many times and was always nice
to me on the show like especially when I
was young and people weren't
um so that was that was kind of weird
you know but also why though I mean I
would think that she was leaving in
other words it's also very cool for our
show yeah I'm not like an idiot yeah so
it was awesome timing in that sense but
um look no one was more a naysayer than
me
like I obviously put my best foot
forward and like tried and I will say
ignorance is bliss I had no idea
the failure rate in that industry like
huge I know but I had no idea like I I
had only heard of or seen like you know
Oprah or a residential or Ellen or like
the view or like you know what I'm
saying I've only heard of like shows
that I'm like oh yeah okay like I didn't
I didn't really know like most people
don't aren't super successful at it so I
I had no idea
foreign